Let's go next to our caller from the nine
one six area code.
Who's calling today from nine one six.
Hi David, this is Curtis.
Hey Curtis, what's up?
Yeah, great to talk to you.
Thanks for doing what you do.
My pleasure.
Um, I have a quick question.
I just thought maybe you could try to clarify
for me.
Um, so I was wondering why you Korean election
interference, conspiracy theory, is that not
contradictory to the Seth rich conspiracy
theory?
How so that this, this might could be interesting.
What do you mean?
Well, from a conservative perspective, isn't
it two different ways of explaining that the
DNC was hacked or the emails were stolen and
or are they different?
Different attacks on the election, you know,
are, cause I think saturate shred allegedly
stole some emails and get past some on the
WikiLeaks, right?
Where you praying theory is that the Ukrainians
hacked the DNC server and they provided it
and they released it to her, the election.
So those not contradictory statements that
some conservatives are using.
Oh, in other words, the hacking of the DNC
is being by some on some conspiracy theorists
being attributed to Seth rich and by other
conspiracy theorists being attributed to Ukraine.
And how could both be true?
They seem like two different explanations
for the same event.
Yeah, I mean if you see like people I can
study, talk to them about both of those conspiracy
theories.
Don't they have to choose one?
They really don't.
Actually that's the funny thing.
I mean because of their, their OD.
So two things on, I mean number one Hannity's
not talking about Seth rich anymore and honestly
I, I actually, I don't even want to say for
sure.
I don't remember specifically whether Hannity
was one of the people pushing the Seth rich
thing.
Now.
I'm trying to think.
I guess maybe he was in any case regardless.
I don't think you're seeing people push both
at the same time.
Seth rich was a couple years ago and you saw
some lingering from it, but they've shifted.
I don't, if they were pushing them both at
the same time, it would be more cartoonishly
hypocritical.
But I think they've just moved on from one
to the other.
Well entity definitely was pushing the sets
rich thing at one time and now it seems like
he's pushing the Ukraine theory and I don't
know, I think they should just be, obviously
hypocrisy is not something that really registers
to a lot of these people, but to try to, you
know, deny the facts and use contradictory
conspiracy theories.
It seems pretty blatant.
Well, this is not a new thing.
I mean, listen, this has been, this has been
their emo.
Look at, look at with the, for example, the
Russia stuff.
For awhile it was, we had no contacts with
Russia or if we did, they were completely
fine and legal and we would do it again.
Like those are also conflicts, right, but
it just doesn't matter.
It's come up with something for anybody.
Trump did this with health insurance for awhile.
It was, I'm going to do a on healthcare.
I'm going gonna do be on healthcare.
I'm going to do see on healthcare.
They were all mutually exclusive, but it was
sort of like pick one that sounds good and
then that's why you should vote for Trump
that did.
This is nothing new.
Right.
I agree.
It's, it's constant change, the story change
of, you know, whatever it takes to get them
through the next month of scandal.
That's exactly right, Curtis.
I appreciate the call.
Thank you.
Thanks Eddie.
All right, take care.